The first law of thermodynamics, the one which
says that the total amount of energy is fixed,
that energy can't be created or destroyed,
Sometimes people say that that law states
that there's no such thing as a free lunch.
That energy is a little bit like money in
a bank account.
You can always account for it, that there
is a ledger
where you can add or subtract and you can
keep track of the energy.
There's a beautiful example of this from Richard
Feynman
where he tries to explain how energy works.
And he says it's a little bit like a child
that has a set of twenty eight wooden blocks
that he uses as toys.
And every day his mum comes in and she counts
the blocks when she puts them back into their box
And every day she finds that there's 28.
One day she finds that there's 26.
And so she reasons that they must be somewhere,
so what she starts doing is looking around,
and she looks behind the bed and sure enough
a couple blocks have ended up there.
Another day she's looking for these blocks
and she only finds 15 or something,
So she looks out the window and sure enough
there are the remaining blocks.
And in many ways, this is very much the same
kind of thing.
Provided you look hard enough, you'll always
find that energy somewhere.
So Feynman has this idea where the child says
"No no no, you're not allowed to look in that box!"
And his mom says "What do you mean I can't
look?"
"No no no you can't!"
The child screams.
What she does is she weighs the box.
She weighs the box over and over again, every
day she weighs it.
And what she notices is a pattern.
Sometimes it weighs a little bit more, sometimes
it weighs a little bit less.
But then she begins to understand what the
pattern is
for how many blocks are actually inside the box.
So you don't necessarily actually need to
see the blocks, you might be able to infer
them in cunning ways.
In this sense, there's this idea that you
don't really ever know how much there is in total
but you're constantly seeing differences,
you're seeing changes.
And we've just become very very clever at
inferring it.
And so one of the things is that this fundamental
rule is something
that in science keeps us very safe.
And whenever that rule is broken, you smell
a rat.
There's a snake oil salesman somewhere who's
trying to pull a fast one on you.